can i ask you a question yes absolutely
do you think that is this the first time
the world
has faced a problem simultaneously
throughout the whole world
uh well how do you compare them to
worldwide world war
ii and they also simultaneously
but maybe not to every individual in
terms of
like it touches every human being on
earth this may be the first time
yeah and also we all are facing the same
problem whereas
during wars people face each other
they're each other's problem
well i am worried about that this is a
virus but we're making it an imaginary
wall
yes i think that's a problem
on the other hand
it's not we are making it that maybe our
politicians are but
i don't feel that you know
we're not um
i don't feel that people feel that way
that they're against other people in
fact i think
people more feel they sort of realize in
some sense they realize the same way
that they realize when they saw that
picture of the whole earth
that there's a lot of other people that
are in the same boat they are
well i'm not saying that this particular
imaginary wall is
necessarily negative because in history
we always see
that when there is a common enemy people
get together right
this is seemed like the first time the
entire earth
identified a common enemy even though
like a virus has existed
forever we live with virus all the time
but
there was not a political social
togetherness in identify wine virus
is all as a common enemy of our humanity
so which which is interesting
permanently change us
because we face for the first time
we've or at least we've realized we're
facing a common enemy before
i think we've done it we've had a common
enemy before but
i don't think it's happened quickly
enough or people were aware of it enough
i mean certainly you know one imagine
that global warming
might have done that but so slowly
but this causes a lot of people to
realize they're sort of in it together
in real time in a way
that i don't think we've ever been
before well in terms of
environmental issue it is also like
when you talk about global warming or
the clean air
clean water it's also a common enemy
it's just
it's more long-term so it's not as
urgent
and this one is like now that is making
people are reacting to it
but i'm hoping like this would make us
realize there are many
other common enemies that we have
for the survival of humanity that is out
there
so that we will deal with it in a more
coherent or collaborative way